marché cumulée seuls les kilomètres face
à la souffrance c'est désormais le
quotidien de véronique cochereau
assistant de direction dans la vie
professionnelle marcheuse d'exception
sur la piste véronique est un cas à part
dans l'athlétisme ce n'est qu'en 2005
qu'elle pose ses empreintes dans le
monde de la marche et la découverte
devient vite une addiction la marche est
une drogue parce que ça me manque donc
je peux pas m'arrêter très longtemps je
sais pas jusqu'où je vais aller mais
c'est une c'est devenu une drogue en
effet oui parce que la plus souillée
j'étais blessé je seule question je me
suis posée est-ce que je vais pouvoir
continuer en 2010 véronique se retrouve
sans entraîneur bernard coadou le patron
de la piste à montigny du propose ses
services ces progrès sont alors
fulgurant en 2012 véronique ba3 record
personnel glane 10 médailles dont trois
aux championnats d'europe en août
dernier à raison de quatre entraînements
hebdomadaires lenny monteyne on enfile
les kilomètres mais parfois avec un peu
trop d'engouement à l'entraînement elle
est toujours là
et elle donne toujours le maximum
entraînements même des fois où il faut
la calmer un peu parce que ça va
toujours un peu trop vite parfois un
petit manque de confiance en elle elle a
toujours peur de ne pas être prête elle
se pose toujours des questions oui mais
est-ce que c'est bien ça pour
l'entraînement qu'il faut faire mais oui
mais oui malgré ses performances la
marcheuse unis montrent elle ne reçoit
aucune aide de la fédération française
d'athlétisme frais d'engagement des
compétitions hébergement jusqu'au
survêtement tricolore véronique finance
tout malgré les récentes performances de
yoann diniz l'athlète du smac regrette
que son sport ne soit pas reconnu à sa
juste valeur n'est pas reconnu je sais
que souvent quand je sors je me fais
moquer de moi dans la rue et cesser une
c'est dur parce que les gens sont pas
construits c'est comme il faut que ces
violents et quand on me dit souvent me
disent tu vous feriez mieux de courir
vous auriez peut maintenant je tournais
genre 11 km heure il rend ce que m c'est
rare que mais en courant avec elle
n'arrive même pas et véronique partage
sa passion avec sa fille de retour sur
les pistes depuis deux saisons ç'a
toujours été un plaisir après j'ai eu
quelques soucis donc j'ai dû arrêter et
puis bah avec les médailles des normands
ça donne toujours plus ou moins envie à
53 ans véronique augereau ne se fixe pas
de limites son plus beau rêve faire
retentir la marseillaise sur un podium
international